we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two David P
here's a you know speaking of Awakenings
Tulsi gabbard had an Awakening and went
from the left to the right Dave Rubin
had an Awakening and went to the left
from the left to the right uh here's a
really good voicemail about the way
these Awakenings differ when it's left
to right versus right to left take a
listen
hey David it's Tommy have you ever
noticed that when people shift political
sides that if they go from the left to
the right usually off the deep end you
know like Jesse dollar more used to be
you know hardcore conservatives like
some terrible things now on the left and
he makes a lot of sense and he's
intelligent and well informed but then
you get people like Tulsi
or diamond and silk who used to be
Democrats and now they're on the
Republican side and they're just out of
their minds what's the deal with that
this is a very interesting observation
very very interesting observation I
think there's a couple reasons why going
from left to right leads to extremist
lunacy and going from right to left is
less commonly leading to that kind of
lunacy by definition I mean when we talk
about what is the right wing the right
wing generally speaking is reactionary
and it is fear oriented if your only
issue for why you go left to right is
you know I realized instead of a 37 top
tax rate we should really have like a 22
flat tax okay
that is not
radical in the sense that many of these
other beliefs are radical and I'm not
aware of anybody who went from left to
right because of a disagreement about
what the top tax rate should be
generally speaking the reasons people go
left to right are based in fear and they
are extraordinarily reactionary it's
stuff about you know they've been
brainwashed about transgender or they've
become convinced that anyone who gets an
abortion is literally a murderer or that
Democrats want to open the floodgates
with Mexican rapists who will rape your
daughters and sell drugs and whatever
right
Theory the the what pulls people to the
right are
ignorant and factually incorrect but
also reactionary fear-based ideologies
and so the people susceptible to such a
drastic 180 because let's be honest
if you're 16 and your political views
change significantly you're just
learning about what the world is like
it's more believable when a 40 year old
man like Dave Rubin or a 40 year old
woman like Tulsi gabbard do a 180 you
have to wonder is it a grift and this is
just they're choosing the most
profitable character to play
or are they so ignorant or susceptible
to cult mentalities that they are
willing to be sucked in by definition
that is going to lead to people being
extreme on the other hand and I agree
people like Jesse dalamore Jank uger
others who used to be on the right and
and go to the left they come to the left
for very non-radical beliefs hey you
know what I've realized we have the
money to provide everybody a basic level
of a standard of living
with the taxes that we are collecting
I want to be part of the movement that
wants to do that it's not fear-based
it's not reactionary it's actually
empathetic and so at its core
I believe that that is the the most
important reason why we see left to
right Awakenings be extraordinarily
extreme and right to left Awakenings
um not be that let me know your thoughts
we have a great bonus show for you today
Raphael Warnock is suing Georgia over
early voting restrictions for the
December 6th runoff U.S the U.S has
fined Airlines U.S government has fined
Airlines seven and a half million
dollars for canceled flights we'll talk
about when this happened and why it's
controversial and relevant and Mitch
McConnell is facing a leadership
challenge from Rick Scott in the Senate
where will this one go we will talk
about it on the bonus show you can sign
up and get instant access at
joinpakman.com